with all new info about space coming in
on a daily basis
we can't help feeling that there is
nothing in the universe we don't know
already
still in spite of the advanced
capabilities of today's technologies and
research equipment
there is still quite a big blank spot
incidentally it is our own earth
thousands of years of investigating the
blue planet
gave mankind a comparatively meager
knowledge about certain phenomena on it
and now i invite you on a brief
expedition
where we'll take a look at some of the
most unusual places
and phenomena on the planet thus the
coalesce super deep borehole
will get us to the earth's interior then
it will be the turn of permafrost to be
checked out
followed by the bermuda triangle the
biggest meteorite ever to have dropped
on the surface of our planet
global extinctions and the most
dangerous asteroid ever detected
a fascinating trip is up ahead let's get
started
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
people have attempted to drill hills on
the ground since the 13th century
the main purpose for such projects was
to take a close look at the diversity of
objects as yet not known to science that
could lie concealed in the depths of our
earth
for example several years ago a team of
geochemists from russia
france and germany discovered an
underground ocean dating back to the
archaean eon
it lies approximately 500 kilometers
deep
and its volume beats the overall amount
of water of all
oceans on the planet's surface this
discovery provided scientists with more
accurate data about the peculiarities of
our planet's formation
there is no doubt that these discoveries
would have been unthinkable without
super deep drilling projects
one of the best examples of these is the
kohler super deep bojol
which maintains the title of the deepest
in the world even a quarter of a century
after it was closed the construction and
development of the kola borehole
facility started back in 1970
and continued for over 20 years its
depth reaches 12
262 meters
the diameter of its opening measures 92
centimeters
the drilling was carried out using the
ural mash 4a drilling rig
to be later superseded at 7263 meters by
ural mash 15 000
whose mass was over 200 tons notably
took about 18 hours for the column to
travel all the way up
or down the chosen drilling site was
located 10 kilometers to the west from
the town of zapolarni
the borehole is situated in the
northeastern part of the baltic shield
and reaches archaean ore bearing rocks
which are typically to be found in
ancient bedrocks of the continental
crust
the site is by all accounts ideal for
super deep drilling
as the kola peninsula is one of the few
continental places on earth that
contains no sedimentary rocks
and whose surface is comprised of
exceptionally ancient rocks
dating back approximately three billion
years
unlike other major super-deep man-made
wells
made for the purposes of oil and gas
extraction works or geological surveys
the object of drilling the cola borehole
was specifically for scientific purposes
to pursue research tasks
its main objective was to confirm
theoretical models of the composition of
the lower layers of the earth's crust
and to find out more about the nature of
their transition to the earth's mantle
the explorers were also going to find
out about the bedrock composition of the
nicoliforous pechanga complex
identify the special features of
geological processes manifestations
and collect more data about the thermal
regime in the crust
as well as about deep water solutions
gases and rock composition
the project was also supposed to help
improve super deep drilling techniques
already existing at the time
and work out methods of complex
geological and physical studies of rocks
and doors
at great depths the drilling works
started on may the 24th
1970. it was plane sailing down to 7 000
meters
as the drill was passing smoothly
through solid homogeneous granite rock
having broken through the 7000 meter
mark the drill entered less
solid stratified rocks and the well
scarred and formed voids
the column would then fail and the drill
would detach itself and fall when its
recovery was attempted
these failures became regular
occurrences and
soon the wells structure assumed a shape
reminding one of a tree with multiple
branches broken off
on june the 6th 1979 the coalesce super
deep borehole beat the 9583 meter record
previously held by the bertha rogers oil
exploratory whale in oklahoma
and in 1983 the depth of the borehole
reached 12
066 meters
after this record was beaten the
drilling was for a short time suspended
when the process was resumed several
months later
the first major failure occurred and the
drilling had to be started again from a
point just seven
kilometers deep by the year 1990
the new hole reached as far down as 12
262 meters however
following several other major failures
the process had to be aborted
with a borehole closing for good four
years later
it was initially expected that the koala
borehole would be instrumental in
discovering clear-cut transition from
granite to basalt
it should be mentioned that due to high
pressure and high temperatures
the granite rocks physical properties
were dramatically affected
the granite samples extracted from the
well would often crumble due to the
sudden
changes in the pressure only extremely
slow lifting of the drill
made it possible to extract a solid
piece of rock which enabled scientists
to make quite a few valuable conclusions
about the earth's deep interior
the major result of the geothermal
studies was information about
temperatures in the well
the indicators proved to be much higher
than initially expected
closer to the surface the rate of
temperature increase accounted for 11
degrees per kilometer
at the depth of two kilometers it grew
to 14 degrees per kilometer
at the depth from 2.2 to 7.5 kilometers
the temperature grew at the rate close
to 24 degrees per kilometer
eventually the temperature of 70 degrees
celsius was registered at the depth of
just five kilometers
and by 12 000 meters the temperature
rose to as much as 220
degrees celsius
new practical information about the
composition of the deepest parts of the
baltic shield greatly complemented
theoretical suppositions
analysis of super deep rocks revealed
data considerably differing from
information
known to science before the launch of
the super deep borehole project
scientific results were also of
practical use
for example shallow copper and nickel
zones were discovered by geologists
and these rocks were suitable for
extraction
at the depth of nine and a half
kilometers an anomalous geochemical
layer of gold was discovered
gold concentration accounted for up to a
gram per 1
ton of the rock and even though gold
mining is hardly feasible at that
greater depth
the very existence of the gold carrying
layer as well as its properties
allowed modeling evolution processes of
these metals with more precision
the length record of the coalish
superdeep borehole was beaten only
recently
and that only by wells drilled for
large-scale oil and gas extraction
one of these is the oil well known as
myersk oil bdo4a
it was drilled in 2008 and is 12
290 meters long
to date the z42 chivo well is the
longest well
on earth extending as far down as twelve
thousand seven hundred meters
however the koala borehole remains the
deepest man-made well
in addition to the borehill's
record-breaking features it also boasts
unique history which over the years has
been shrouded by innumerable legends and
mysterious myths
many of them were prompted by various
failures the scientists had to face
but were not always able to identify
what had caused them
for example in 1995 an explosion of
inexplicable nature
originated at the deepest point of the
well and the drilling had to be stopped
the cause of this phenomenon has never
been identified
the supervisor of the operations david
miranovich guberman confirmed that a
bizarre noise had been heard prior to
the explosion
interestingly several days later nothing
of the kind took place at the same depth
it is possible that the cores lay in a
failure of the drill itself
or else an encounter with a substance
not yet known to science
it is hardly unfeasible as such deep
layers of the globe
still remain almost unexplored
the coales super deep borehole has
travelled only a minuscule portion of
the whole way to the center of the earth
the full distance is 6371 kilometers
the scientists working at the well hoped
to get to the mantle at least
but to achieve this it would have taken
another 30 or 40 kilometers
but even as it is what they did manage
to carry out
borders on fantasy to this day
not a single apparatus has gone that
deep underground
today geology is advancing on a par with
space exploration
and research involving drilling is
comparable to space exploration using
telescopes
which is so familiar to us geologists
cherish some ambitious plans too
and while one part of the scientific
community concerns themselves with how
to reach other planets
another part studies the makeup of our
own earth
and is busy figuring out how to get as
far as its center
permafrost is the part of the upper
layer of the earth's crust
characterized by sub-zero temperatures
of rocks and soils which never thaws
the name is self-explanatory if you look
at it closer
the total area of permafrost on our
planet accounts for 35 million square
kilometers
just to compare it is 5 million more
than the area of africa
most of permafrost is to be found in the
northern parts of america
europe asia and the antarctic
interestingly there is not a speck of it
in australia
the temperature in the permafrost soils
and rocks never rises above zero
with the depth of the layer sometimes
reaching more than one thousand meters
the deepest point of permafrost is
registered in the upper waters of the
ville river in yakutia
the record deepest point is 1 370 meters
down below
it takes a rather long time for a layer
of permafrost this thick to form
just to give you an idea it takes one
winter for the ground to freeze
approximately one meter deep
assuming winter never gave way to spring
the ground would freeze four meters deep
in the course of one year
however the bigger the depth the slower
the ground freezes
and it would take about a thousand years
for the layer of permafrost to reach as
deep down as 116 meters
and about a million years to reach a
depth of 700 meters
permafrost is a global large-scale
phenomenon
covering not less than 25 percent of all
land on the globe
at the same time most of permafrost
today is slowly but inexorably thawing
and this process will realistically
cause staggering damage to the world
economy
it is believed that by the end of the
21st century the thawing will have led
to damages worth 43 trillion dollars
it is the increased rate of global
warming with the destruction of the
foundations of constructions and areas
with permafrost as one of its direct
consequences that may become the chief
reason for such damage
still all this may be realistically
prevented if mankind takes necessary
measures to curb global warming and its
harmful effects
as soon as this century incidentally
this danger is not the worst that may
before humankind if permafrost melts
there are other threats lurking in
permafrost that may manifest themselves
literally at any moment
for example it may contain frozen
viruses
whose age may be tens of thousands of
years or else it may cause outbreaks of
more recent diseases like plagues of
different sorts
including siberian plague also known as
anthrax
in 2014 russian and french scientists
discovered a giant virus called
pithovirus sibericum
comparable with bacteria in terms of its
size the find was made in 30
000 year permafrost it proved to be
viable but fortunately
wasn't dangerous for humans the virus
preferred exclusively some kinds of
amoebas to parasite on
and even the worst case scenario
wouldn't seriously affect the local
ecosystem
still such frozen finds may
theoretically cause small scale
outbreaks of diseases among some animals
thus there may be a correlation between
occasional outbreaks of the so-called
pdv
and thawing of ice as a result thousands
of seals in the arctic
and sea otters in alaska have fallen
prey to the virus for several years
with astonishing regularity besides in
the past when there was an
outbreak of an epidemic in northern
areas animal carcasses used to be dumped
underground
today when they thaw these burial sites
pose a grave threat to us
no pun intended diseases like a plague
may suddenly start spreading at any
moment
for example there was an outbreak of
siberian plague in 2016 in the yamal
region of the russian federation
at the time this phenomenon was largely
associated with the anomalous heatwave
that year
which caused an animal burial site to
thaw with the virus escaping from its
centuries-long confinement
but it is not only siberian plague
spores that are to be found in
permafrost
for example in 2007 french scientists
unearthed microorganisms which were
still quite active and
none the worst for their age that could
be anything up to 500
000 years one more example
in 2018 some bacteria were discovered in
the interior of the frozen mammoth
mountain in yakutia
their possible age is estimated at three
and a half million years
today in every permafrost area such
prehistoric burial sites are paid close
attention to
and measures are taken to make these
territories unavailable to people
and animals outbreaks of viral
infections of this kind are
comparatively unlikely dangers
as humanity has had to cope with similar
epidemics before
but there are other secrets concealed in
permafrost
one of them is the formation of gas
hydrate fields and in particular
methane hydrate this is a supramolecular
kind of compound
consisting of methane and water which is
resistant to low temperatures and
extreme pressure
methane hydrate also known as methane
cloth rate
is the most widespread gas hydrate in
nature
its fields are estimated at 10 to the
power of 16 kilograms
which is even more than global oil
reserves
these are as big as 2 times 10 to the
power of 14 kilograms
methane is known as one of several
greenhouse gases
and the result of its release could be
one of the things causing global warming
still its effect on the process is not
as serious as that of other greenhouse
gases like water vapor or carbon dioxide
the point is that methane stays in the
atmosphere only for 10 or 12 years
nevertheless if in theory methane were
to be released from all deposits in the
world
it would cause temperatures to soar and
all other hydrates to destabilize
this would unleash an irreversible
process rapidly gaining in intensity
as a reversible as a gunshot after the
trigger has been pulled
the direct result of permafrost thawing
is the release of methane into the
atmosphere and a gradual buildup of the
greenhouse effect
after that the average temperature on
the earth will increase
which will cause the release of
greenhouse gases all over the planet
this will naturally make permafrost thaw
quicker which will lead to the
greenhouse effect
gradually but irreversibly intensifying
that is why the theory about the
probability of this event is referred to
as the clathrate gun hypothesis
according to the original version of
this hypothesis the so-called clathrate
gun may cause
sudden self-reinforcing global warming
and it may take the process
less than an average human life to be
completed
it is suggested that such decomposition
of methane hydrates may have caused
sharp changes in the global ocean and
the earth's atmosphere in the past
and mass extinction events with direct
consequences of these processes
the chief result of methane release is a
temperature increase
this is posited to be the decisive
factor of a temperature growth by 6
degrees celsius during the permian
extinction
in addition there are theories
suggesting that following methane
release
the level of available oxygen in the
atmosphere will drop
which in itself is an alarming prospect
in fact the content of co2 in the
atmosphere today has reached an all-time
high
and it keeps growing exponentially so if
this scenario were to run its course in
this manner
clathrate methane destabilization may
turn into an irreversible
self-reinforcing mechanism that would
cause temperatures to rise to dangerous
levels
as a result of a substantial and
continuous temperature increase in the
ocean
deposits lying under the bottom will
heat up to a point sufficient to start
the process of decomposition of the
deepest layers of clathrate methane
it should be mentioned that it will take
several millennia to get this process
started recent studies in the siberian
arctic revealed that even at this point
millions of tons of methane have been
released probably due to permafrost
structures at the sea bottom
following this in some areas methane
concentration has grown hundredfold
methane release in the modern world used
to be estimated at half a megaton a year
today not less than 1400 gigatons of
carbon in the form of methane is trapped
underwater below permafrost in the
arctic
incidentally permafrost thawing would
occasionally occur in the history of our
planet
that is why some researchers claim that
the processes taking place today can
hardly be detrimental to mankind in any
way
still human impact on the environment
should be monitored at all times
and we will always have to have an eye
on our activities
and make sure that they do not grow more
and more damaging to
our nature
the bermuda triangle is an area in the
atlantic
located off the southeastern tip of
florida
part of the triangle's water zone is in
the bahamas
the area itself is between miami the
bermudez
and puerto rico the area covers over
thousand square 140.000 navigation in
these parts is extremely difficult on
account of innumerable shells
besides frequent cyclones and storms
originate here
the turbulence of the waters here may be
explained by the fact that the bermudas
are located in the open ocean
and should a storm simultaneously begin
in the northern and southern parts and
near the coast of florida the three
storms will collide
thus generating enormous waves
all sorts of vessels were wrecked in
these waters throughout the long history
of seafaring
and the natural disasters responsible
for these accidents are quite ordinary
and are very well known to mariners who
often have to face them in the open
ocean
for example the 165 meter long cyclops
we've already mentioned is likely to
have fallen victim to lateral waves
there are several facts in favor of this
version
to enhance the capacity of the ship its
bottom was constructed flat
which made it vulnerable to the assault
of lateral waves
it is also possible that the vessel was
smashed by a single gigantic wave
these may suddenly appear even in fine
weather as opposed to regular waves
it is these natural phenomena that are
likely to have caused this and other
vessels to perish in these waters
as waves of this kind catch up with the
ship abruptly and without warning
the crew are too taken aback to send out
a mayday call in the nick of time
but even one story of this kind was
enough to sparkle instant interest in
the newly born legend that was to spread
across the rest of the world
in the blink of an eye so there was no
way journalists could overlook this
matter
the second half of the 20th century
heralded a stream of unverified
information about the bermuda triangle
in newspapers
and very soon it acquired the reputation
we're used to today
and is firmly lodged in people's minds
as an anomalous
bizarre mysterious place is it such an
unfathomable mystery though
it wasn't only the vanished ships that
were the main cause of interest in the
area
the most sensational incident was the
disappearance of five navy bombers on
the 5th of december 1945.
on reading the story in a newspaper you
would also most likely not fail to see
it as a mysterious occurrence
at first glance it does appear
inexplicable
the flight leader was an experienced
pilot and the flight was taking place in
fine weather
the search for the planes revealed
nothing the only evidence of a crash
being deciphered radio transcripts of
the men
it can be heard that they were
completely disoriented and had no clue
as to their whereabouts
all their compasses seem to have failed
but if one looks deeper into the mata
mysticism and conspiracy theories give
way to something more down to earth
and eventually a perfectly logical
explanation can be found for such air
and water accidents
one of the most popular versions is the
giant waves theory
these may rise as high as 30 meters
it goes without saying that planes
wouldn't be within their reach
but even a truly enormous vessel may
easily be sunk by a wave like that
the point is that a storm at sea may
persevere for several days
if two waves overlap they get mutually
enlarged
and there occurs what is known as
interference that's the special term for
this phenomenon
as a result the size these waves may
grow to
is mind-boggling and even
storm-resistant vessels may be unable to
withstand their crushing force
unlike with a tsunami these waves appear
abruptly even in fine weather
so it's downright impossible to see them
coming the fact that hardly any debris
is recovered after crashes or shipwrecks
is accounted for by the nature of the
bottom of the bermuda triangle
its relief is one of the most elaborate
in the atlantic ocean
for one thing a huge trench traverses
the triangle
it is called the puerto rico trench and
its depth reaches 8
742 meters the length of the trench
measures 1754
kilometers and its width about 97
kilometers
this is the deepest point in the
atlantic ocean
besides the bottom of the bermuda
triangle is extremely diverse
and is rich in continental slopes
shelves
shells middle and marginal plateaus
abyssal plains and deep flowing
straights
this per se doesn't account for the
shipwrecks but it certainly makes any
search for wreckage practically
impossible
speaking about the disappearance of
planes the key to the riddle may also
lie at the bottom of the ocean
and may have to do with tectonics
seismic activity at the bottom of the
triangle may cause magnetic
perturbations
which in their turn may cause navigation
devices to malfunction
by the way frequent underwater
earthquakes result not only in methane
eruptions
but may also generate infrasound which
in its turn interferes with
radio waves this could be why the
electronic equipment failed
and the pilots lost their bearings
infrasound is also pernicious for the
human psyche
having been exposed to it especially for
a prolonged period
the pilots and seamen may have lost
treason and acted uncontrollably
for example the mariners may have
abandoned their ships
or else lost the ability of navigating
them responsibly
however the version that has most
evidence has to do with gas eruptions as
a result of decomposition of methane
hydrate
in the fields at the bottom of the ocean
these fields are formed after a great
many years of decomposed organisms
accumulating on the ocean floor
according to this concept big methane
rich bubbles are formed on the water's
surface
their density is low to such a point the
chips cannot help capsizing
and so sink instantly when methane
reaches the surface
water becomes saturated by bubbles of
gas and a ship loses its buoyancy
on several occasions geologists observed
entire oil platforms submerging
underwater
as a result of such eruptions talking
about air accidents
it seems feasible that while floating in
the air methane may cause them to fall
for example the air density could
decrease to such a point
that the carrying capacity of aircraft
could drop as well
and the outer meters would malfunction
it was experimentally confirmed that a
ship really could sink
relatively fast following the effect of
this phenomenon
provided the culprit gas bubble is
bigger than or equal to the ship's
dimensions
interestingly methane hydrate is to be
found in other areas of the global ocean
in the sea of arkotsk for example and
many other places across the planet
unlike with the bermuda triangle however
those places didn't
receive much publicity as no such
outstandingly sensational accidents or
shipwrecks took place there
we can't but admit that many of the
reports about what happens in the
bermuda triangle
are seriously exaggerated and ships and
aircraft do vanish in places all over
the world from time to time
let's try to sum up all the above
mentioned and look at the bermuda
triangle from a different perspective
if we consider it as an area in the
ocean with a high rate of cyclones and
storms
the statistical figures on plane crashes
and shipwrecks
shouldn't really strike us as
particularly high and when people
finally get to the heart of the mata in
their investigations of the causes of
those tragic accidents we will probably
see that there is nothing downright
bizarre about it all
after all but while it is still shrouded
in mystery
the bermuda triangle enjoys keen
interest of a great number of people
on our planet earth
first of all let's dwell upon the terms
used in science to refer to such
astronomical bodies
the term asteroid was coined at the
beginning of the 19th century
it was used to refer to star-like dots
that could be seen through a telescope
and which differed from planets by their
appearance of disks
that was the reason why asteroids used
to be classified in the same category as
small planets
up until 2006 the defining parameter
being their diameter
that had to measure not less than 30
meters celestial objects falling short
of this size
are called meteoroids astronomical
bodies that eventually burn up in our
atmosphere fall into the category of
meteors
and those bodies that make it to the
surface of our earth or any other large
object in space
are referred to as meteorites on impact
most of them have a mass ranging from
several grams to dozens of tons
on average the overall mass of
meteorites falling on the surface of our
planet every year
may reach as much as approximately two
thousand tons
generally meteorites enter the earth's
atmosphere at speeds of approximately 50
kilometers per second
as a result of such rapid movement we're
able to observe
heated fireballs of intense brightness
on reaching the surface of a planet a
meteorite would have experienced heating
and ablation on its way
and its mass would have become smaller
than what it was on atmospheric entry
as for tiny celestial bodies with no
mass to speak of
they burn up almost completely after
experiencing speeds of over 25
kilometers per second
when a meteorite makes it through the
earth's atmosphere it loses its forward
velocity as it decelerates due to air
drag
this in its turn subsequently changes
the trajectory of the fall
for example if the original trajectory
of the meteorite's fall is horizontal
as a result of deceleration on its way
it may drop towards the surface of a
planet
almost vertically simultaneously the
fireball gets dimmer during the process
and the object itself considerably cools
down
but if an astronomical body manages to
reach the surface of the earth in the
end
it collides with it and this phenomenon
is known as an impact event
as a rule a crater is usually formed
upon impact
and there is a risk of a fire an
earthquake or a tsunami in the area
an impact event is able to trigger some
really disastrous processes
some theories have it that it is
meteorite sinful that is to blame for
major extinction events of species in
the past
when an astronomical object of this kind
collides with the surface of our planet
at high velocity
a staggering amount of energy is
released accompanied by powerful
explosion processes resulting in the
formation of a crater
with a diameter by far larger than that
of the meteorite itself
for example the well-known crater in
arizona with a diameter of 1.2
kilometers was formed
about 50 000 years ago when the surface
was hit by a 15 meter astronomical body
with a mass of approximately 300
000 tons the force of the explosion upon
impact
was comparable to the explosion of 8 000
atomic bombs of the kind
dropped on hiroshima
following an impact event there may
appear rock formations
as a result of a process known as shock
metamorphism
and some mineral deposits like copper
and nickel deposits in the sudbury basin
have come to be
thanks to this phenomenon meteorite
craters may measure up to 500 kilometers
there may even be settlements within
their borders
for example the red fort crater located
in south africa
was dubbed after the town inside it with
the crater's diameter reaching 300
kilometers
just to compare it is about 1.3 of the
cheek shaloob crater
or the sudbury basin the object was
formed over two billion years ago
as a result of the earth getting hit by
an asteroid with a diameter measuring
approximately 10 kilometers
vreda fort is considered to hold the
second place among the most
ancient craters on earth and is beaten
only by suaviavi whose age is about 2.4
billion years
and which is thus several hundred
million years older
the object is also the largest crater
apart from the unexplored wilkes-land
crater
with a diameter of approximately 500
kilometers covered by an ice shield in
antarctica
the wilkes-land crater is likely to have
been formed on a collision with an
asteroid
whose diameter measured about 60
kilometers
at first scientists were unable to
determine the date of its formation
but recent studies revealed that the
crater's age is approximately 250
million years
it is highly likely that this impact
event caused the mass extinction in the
permian period
it would have been dramatic to such a
point that 96
of all ocean species and 73 percent of
all land species
died out as a result of this collision
however
to date this version has not been
confirmed as exploration of the crater
is difficult due to its location
it is worth mentioning that not all
meteorites leave giant craters upon
impact
and many astronomical bodies hit our
earth with by far less force
the hoba meteorite for instance didn't
leave any large crater
but it is this object that is the
largest astronomical body
ever to have been found on the surface
of our planet
this object is the biggest piece of iron
of natural origin
on earth as for its mass it is estimated
at 66 tons
the meteorite's volume is 9 cubic meters
and its diameter measures about 3 meters
hoba hit the earth approximately 80 000
years ago
although his discovery was made only as
late as in 1920
near the town of grotfontain which is
situated in the republic of namibia in
africa
it was a chance discovery as neither a
crater nor any other signs of the four
were to be seen that would be indicative
of the impact
a possible reason for this could have
been hobis deceleration in the
atmosphere
[Music]
the object's surface is smooth and flat
which is untypical of most meteorites
as for its chemical composition hobe is
a dense metal object with 84 percent of
iron
16 of nickel and also traces of cobalt
even though the meteorite has never been
weighed its original mass is estimated
to have been approximately 90 tons
interestingly the hoba meteorite didn't
cause much damage to the planet's
surface which is really stupefying
as a rule the gravity of consequences
depends directly on where such an object
falls
for example the meteorite whose force
supposedly caused the extinction of
dinosaurs
fell in the vicinity of the yucatan
peninsula hitting shallow waters in an
area where there were gypsum or plaster
rock deposits at the time
as a result large amounts of sulfates
were released in the atmosphere
which in its stern led to the prolonged
period of global winter
since the asteroids struck the earth at
an angle of about 60 degrees
a great amount of dust was released into
the atmosphere
as for the collision itself it would
have caused a tsunami of about 80 meters
a high temperature shock wave would have
swept across the entire planet's surface
causing wildfires on its way and
particles of dust and suit floating in
the air
triggered a climate change when direct
sun rays rebounded from the dust cloud
not reaching the surface of the planet
this cloud would have persisted for
several years it goes without saying
that the chance of a collision of the
kind taking place today
is infinitely small as the fall of a
large meteorite is a rare occasion
however man hasn't yet come up with a
contingency plan to ensure our safety
should a threat of this kind actually
materialize
just to give an example one of the most
dangerous asteroids on a collision
course with our earth
is 1950 d a a small near-earth object
with the highest
palermo rating of the potential hazard
of impact the closest approach with the
asteroid
is going to take place in 2032 and the
odds of its hitting the earth in the
year 2880 are estimated at 1 in 300 at
the most
in this case the human race is going to
be affected by catastrophic calamities
such as a global climate change with a
significant part of the biosphere
getting destroyed as a result
the diameter of 1950 d a is 1.3
kilometers
and its mass hasn't been estimated yet
the second most potentially dangerous
celestial traveler is considered to be
the banu asteroid which is estimated to
be just 300 000 kilometers away from our
planet
in the year 2135 the date of its
possible info
fluctuates between the years 2175 and
as this is the period when the banu
asteroid will approach the earth
relatively closely on 78 occasions
but the odds of it hitting us are one in
four thousand
[Music]
the asteroid's average diameter measures
over 510 meters
and its mass is estimated to be between
60 and 78 million tons
a collision of an object like that with
the earth is tantamount to the explosion
of a bomb of 1150 megatons
in tnt equivalent just to compare
the most powerful bomb ever tested by
humans on earth
was the tsar bomber with a power of
about 58 megatons
in tnt equivalent it is quite likely
that
science will soon find a way of changing
trajectories of potentially dangerous
astronomical objects
heading towards us from the infinite
depths of outer space
but before it is made possible we can
only hope that no
impact event of such devastating force
will take place on our earth for at
least the next
thousand years
the evolution of life on earth was
anything but linear
there were periods of higher diversity
as well as periods of almost total
extinction
this was deduced following the analysis
of fossils unearthed at paleontological
digging sites
in the past 540 million years there have
been
five major and about 20 minor extinction
events
however the most global crisis of our
planet's biosphere
occurred much earlier approximately 2.1
billion years ago
the first living organisms are posited
to have appeared on earth rather early
approximately but not quite 4 billion
years ago
that is about 400 million years after
the planet's surface
had become more or less suitable for
life even so
the earth of that period can't have
looked hospitable
barren rocks dense clouds frequent
storms and earthquakes
and an atmosphere devoid of oxygen made
up of mostly nitrogen
methane and carbon dioxide
this was the age of primitive
microorganisms archaea and bacteria
most of which used an oxygenic
photosynthesis
that is a kind of photosynthesis where
oxygen is not produced
apart from these creatures it is thought
that there were many forms falling in
between that couldn't be classified as
either living beings or not living
objects with a satisfying
degree of certainty about 2.7 billion
years ago
their emerged oxygenic photosynthesis
the kind of photosynthesis familiar to
us where oxygen is produced
this form is still used by the
overwhelming majority of plants and
unicellular algae
anaerobic organisms cannot live in an
oxygen-rich environment
that is why ancient algae used oxygen as
a weapon
they released it as a byproduct of their
life activity
and this waste killed their competitors
this way algae not only protected their
turf but also spread further to cover
larger areas to dwell on
at first oxygen was spent on oxidation
of rocks in habitats of aerobic
organisms
colonies in this manner oxygen pockets
were formed
small areas of oxidized minerals
gradually
oxygen went on to spread in the
atmosphere oxidizing methane
sulphur compounds and iron not able to
exist in an environment rich in oxygen
most anaerobic organisms died out with
those of them remaining around
confined to underground pockets where
oxygen didn't reach
thus the tables were turned in the
biosphere with the oxygen breathing
organisms becoming the majority and
spreading across larger areas
and the former planet owners forced to
remain in some limited areas
with the spread of the new organisms the
content of gases like methane and carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere dropped
methane oxidized forming water and
eventually carbon dioxide
with the latter taking active part in
photosynthesis
all this reduced the greenhouse effect
and the earth's surface
considerably curled the so-called
huronian glaciation started
approximately 2.1 billion years ago
and continued for about 300 million
years until the sun's luminosity and
tectonic makeovers had heated up the
earth
this was a time when single cell
microorganisms were evolving extremely
slowly
constantly thwarted by an occasional
prolonged global ice age
the period has earned a great number of
nicknames like the great oxidation
or oxygenation event oxygen catastrophe
and oxygen crisis to name but a few
even though not really swift this event
was definitely large scale and global
practically all the biodiversity of the
non-oxygen period was eliminated
and evolution was greatly hampered by
global glaciation for a good billion
years
however in the aftermath there emerged a
more
energy efficient method of nutrition
approximately 540 million years ago the
phanerozoic eons started
sometimes referred to as the period of
visible life
it was peculiar for vigorous evolution
of multicellular species
and in fact it is actually still in
progress
many creatures of that age looked really
bizarre
and didn't resemble any of their today's
descendants
suddenly about 450 million years ago
some unknown factor abruptly interfered
with the act of evolution of life forms
the proposed causes include a cosmic
gamma-ray burst
volcanic activity and even a large
celestial object impact
as it is from 25 to 50 percent of all
living beings became extinct within 7
million years
this series of extinction events dubbed
the ordovician siluarian extinction
was hard on trilobites mollusks and some
other marine invertebrates of the time
the late paleozoic era that followed
this extinction event
heralded active evolution of flora on
land
the first amphibians and reptiles
emerged in that time too
fishes were actively evolving
establishing their dominance in all
fresh water and saline bodies of water
approximately 372 million years ago the
so-called
devonian extinction started it occurred
in several stages that were alternately
followed by comparatively peaceful
periods
peaceful they may have been but even so
the extinction rate of species was
higher than average
the most likely reason for this
extinction is posited to be this
land plants of the time sported long and
powerful roots
which enabled them to extract nutrients
from much deeper down in the soil than
before
when waters seeped through soils that
were loosened by plants roots
great amounts of nutrients were washed
into the ocean
as a result algae were positively
thriving there
in the abundance of food and light the
rotting of these algae reduced oxygen
dissolved in the water
and the organisms inhabiting the sea
bottom were simply smothered with
nothing to breathe
in the aftermath about 70 percent of the
marine species at that time are
estimated to have died out
including practically all species
forming coral reefs
this triggered global irreversible
changes in the biosphere of the global
ocean
many genera and families vanished
completely
and the vacated space was filled by
others
in the carboniferous period which
followed tree ferns exploded in numbers
all over the planet's surface also there
emerged gymnosperm trees and conifers
it is in this period that rich deposits
of coal were formed which is still
widely used by mankind and various
industries
speaking about the fauna this was the
time when insects thrived
that's when the giant millipede
arthropleura was around
which measured two and a half meters the
mega neura
a giant dragonfly with a wingspan of up
to one meter
and the boom in a scorpius a scorpion
measuring 70 centimeters
the insects were of these unbelievable
sizes on account of exceptionally high
concentrations of oxygen in the
atmosphere which at that time reached a
staggering 35 percent
the permian triassic extinction event
also informally referred to as the great
dying occurred about 251 253 million
years ago
marking the transition from the permian
to the triassic period
it proved to be the most massive and
global in the entire history of
multicellular life
digging showed that up to 95 percent of
marine species
and up to 70 percent of land species
vanished from the face of the earth as a
result
interestingly this disaster was rather
swift by geological standards
it took just up to 200 000 years
later it would take not less than 50
million years for biodiversity to
recover for land species
and about 100 million years for marine
species
trilobites a great number of marine and
vertebrates and microorganisms were on
the verge of extinction
insects shrank in size they stopped
looking like horror film creatures on
the loose
and instead assumed in appearance of
today's tiny and numerous creatures
the reasons for the permian triassic
extinction event
still haven't been established with
certainty among the proposed hypotheses
we may single out robust volcanic
activity as one of the most likely ones
others worth mentioning are a collision
of our earth with a large celestial
object
climate change and active methane
emissions following biological or
tectonic activities
there is no single answer to this
question yet
in the triassic period which followed
the permian triassic extinction event
vertebrates vigorously evolved this is
when archosaurs emerged the prehistoric
saurians crocodiles and dinosaurs were
to evolve from
the triassic period also produced first
mammals
although they were not so widespread at
that time
about 200 million years ago the triassic
jurassic extinction event began
sometimes called the end
triassic extinction having lasted for
approximately 10
000 years it marked the transition from
the triassic to the jurassic period
the event claimed about half of known
species on the earth of that time
they included various reptiles and
amphibians that vocated a number of
ecological niches
this allowed dinosaurs to establish
their dominance on the planet
and sustain it for the next 130 million
years
incidentally the reasons for the
anthracic extinction event are not known
either
and in fact there isn't a single
hypothesis today that would sound
sufficiently convincing the jurassic and
cretaceous periods that followed the
triassic jurassic extinction event were
the times when dinosaurs thrived and
flourished
but these giant saurians were not the
sole inhabitants of our planet at the
time
this is when the forefathers of today's
birds flowering plants and corals
evolved
as well as small furry warm-blooded
animals
mammals even though these small
creatures didn't look quite as
impressive compared to tremendous
dinosaurs in all their glory
they firmly held their ecological ground
and steadily progressed in their
revolution
mammals got their chance at the end of
the cretaceous period
that is about 66 million years ago
what occurred then was the most
well-known and a rather large-scale mass
extinction event
referred to as the cretaceous tertiary
according to the first and most popular
hypothesis
the extinction was caused by a giant
celestial object impact
everyone would have heard of a meteorite
supposedly killing off all dinos
nevertheless there is no hard evidence
in favor of this version
either way the upshot was that all
dinosaurs died out
alongside a great number of conifers
algae and mollusks
the cretaceous tertiary extinction event
heralded the beginning of a new geologic
era
the cenozoic which is still in progress
throughout this era
mammals birds and flowering plants have
been actively evolving
and spreading across the earth mammals
settled all over the planet
inhabiting it literally everywhere from
tropical areas to ice caps of the poles
and from the depths of the oceans and
the planet's interior to air currents
up high eventually evolution produced
mankind
even though you would expect people
today to be enlightened enough
there are still those who do not believe
in evolution
however the theory of evolution is not
something to believe in
it is a scientific theory based on facts
the theory of the evolution of species
has come a long way and has undergone
serious revisions since its original
version proposed by charles darwin back
in 1859
still the basic principles of the theory
are the same
and to date the theory of evolution is
the only
serious scientific theory that
accurately describes the process of the
evolution of species and the origin of
new creatures
according to some scientists we are now
living in the epoch of the sixth mass
extinction event
they also call it the holocene or
anthropocene extinction
thousands of species have died out in
the past 10 000
years around 900 species have vanished
from the face of the earth in the past
500 years today about 40 percent of
amphibian species
and 25 percent of mammal species are
under the threat of extinction
and it looks like one of the chief
reasons for this is human activity
will humanity be able to tackle this
threat
will life go one step further of the
order as it was always the case
after every major mass extinction event
there is no way of knowing it now
the earth's biosphere boasts a great
potential for recovery and evolution
which by no means implies that it
doesn't need our care
after all the earth is our only home
large objects do approach our planets
now and then
for example on the 14th of november 2020
asteroid 2020 vt4 with a diameter
measuring about 10 meters past our earth
at a distance of 383 kilometers from the
surface
that is below the international space
station and most satellites
even though known potential threats are
monitored by scientists at all times
the problem is that most asteroids are
rather dark objects
whose dimensions are quite modest by
space standards which makes them hard to
detect
however an explosion caused by an impact
of a celestial body with a diameter of
just 10
meters would be tantamount to the atomic
bombing of hiroshima
it may not leave any radioactive waste
but a blast this powerful would wipe a
little town
right off the face of the earth an
asteroid with a diameter measuring 50
meters
that is as big as a modern multi-storey
building would unleash a power of
several dozen kilotons on impact
which would be enough to raise an entire
city almost to the ground
if an asteroid this large were to fall
into an ocean
it would cause a tsunami reaching up to
10 meters
which would drink destruction all the
way it went traveling for hundreds and
thousands of kilometers from the site of
its impact
where this asteroid's diameter to
measure a kilometer or so
it would cause mass destruction
throughout an entire continent
the force of the explosion on impact
could reach as much as thousands of
megatons and tnt equivalent
and its consequences would haunt the
planet for many years to come
it is highly likely that the human
civilization would not survive a
calamity of this scale
nor would other living creatures with
the only exception of protozoans and
exceptionally enduring organisms
mass extinction events did take place in
the history of our earth
the most notorious of them cretaceous
tertiary extinction event
about 66 million years ago it is posited
that dinosaurs and a number of other
species died out as a result of it
as for the most large-scale mass
extinction event it took place
approximately 251 million years ago
coming in between the permian and the
triassic periods
based on results of paleontological
diggings it was estimated that about 90
percent of sea species and 70 percent
land species died out as a result
one of the things that caused both of
these dramatic calamities
is believed to be the fall of a large
asteroid
today the number of potentially
dangerous objects is estimated to be in
the region of one and a half to two
thousand
although this number may reach four to
six thousand according to the data
provided by the wise telescope
since they're so small and dark these
celestial objects are rather hard to
spot
for example the size of the asteroid
dubbed 2008 dc3
which burned up in the atmosphere just
above sudan in 2008
was anything from two to five meters it
was spotted just 20
hours before it would have impacted the
earth fortunately
nobody was hurt there is a special
rating scale known as the palermo scale
it is a generalized scale reflecting
potential impact risk
posed by this or that celestial body
which takes into account the body's
kinetic energy
and the probability of hitting the earth
the higher the value the bigger the
threat to our planet
if a body's palermo scale value is below
-2
this body is practically safe asteroids
with values between -2 and 0 do not pose
any immediate threat
but require monitoring at all times as
for objects with a value above zero
they're realistically dangerous for the
earth at this point
there isn't a single celestial object
out there with a positive palermo scale
value
and there are only two asteroids in the
yellow alert zone
that is their value is between minus two
and zero
both of them fall into the category of
the apollo asteroids
celestial bodies whose perihelion lies
closer to the sun than the earth's
aphelion
and whose orbital semi-major axis is
bigger than that of the earth
thus these objects cross our planet's
orbit from the outside
the bennu asteroid designation 1999
rq36 with a potential hazard index value
minus 1.69 poses a smaller threat of the
two
in the year 2135 it will find itself
just 300
000 kilometers away from the earth which
is slightly closer to us than the moon
bennu's average diameter measures
approximately 500 meters
and the asteroid's mass is anything
between 60 to 78 million tons
if it were to collide with our earth the
resulting explosion would be tantamount
to about a thousand megatons and tnt
equivalent
which would almost certainly cause major
catastrophic disasters
all over the planet in 2016
nasa launched the osiris-rex probe to
bennu in order to obtain
samples of the minerals making up the
asteroid the probe is scheduled to get
back to the earth in 2023
the more hazardous of the two asteroids
is 1950 d a
with a palomo scale value minus 1.42
today it has the highest probability of
hitting our earth
its diameter measures about 1.3
kilometers
and its mass can be anything from 2 to 4
billion tons
1950 da's orbit is elongated and
elliptical
and it crosses the orbits of our earth
and mars
1950 da's closest approach to the earth
is expected in 2035
but a hazardous approach will take place
only as late as on the 16th of march
what would await us if the asteroid did
impact the earth
let's assume no preventive measures have
been successful to deflect this body
and the disaster is inevitable
an enormous chunk of rock with a
diameter almost one and a half
kilometers
and a mass that could be two to four
billion tons heading towards the earth
at a speed of about 14 kilometers per
second
this would be the speed of 1950 d a at
the moment it hit the earth if an impact
event
did occur as estimated by nasa
of course part of the matter making up
1950 da would burn up and disperse in
the atmosphere as the asteroid slowed
down
and the main body would be likely to
break up into several large rocks and a
great number of small bits
depending on their size each of them
would cause an explosion of not less
than 20 kilotons on impact with the
earth's crust
that's the average power of a modern
nuclear bomb with a comparatively modest
charge
the overall power of the explosions
would most likely be over one and a half
thousand megatons
with a bombarded area larger than that
of europe
all constructions within the radius of
300 to 500 kilometers would be raised to
the ground
and even reinforced underground bunkers
wouldn't guarantee enough safety
the energy of the shock wave would allow
it to sweep around the earth several
times while gradually slowing down
and bringing more destruction on its way
with every lap
if the asteroid were to fall into an
ocean a giant
tsunami would rise 40 meters or higher
tsunamis normally travel for thousands
of kilometers and as they go their
destructive forces practically don't
diminish
therefore coastal areas of the
continents lying near the site of the
impact would be submerged in water
with cities and villages effectively
wiped out
multiple impacts of bits of rock would
raise tons of dust in the atmosphere
winds would scatter these dense clouds
all over the sky
and most sunlight would not reach the
planet which would cause a sharp
temperature fall
this phenomenon is known as nuclear
winter
it is highly probable that an impact of
this scale would affect not only the
crust
but the mantle as well the shock wave
would wake up volcanoes
and they would erupt all over the planet
which in its turn would cause the second
wave of tsunamis and earthquakes
tons of ash released in the atmosphere
would contribute to further temperature
drops
there is quite a popular belief that
after an asteroid hit
the earth it would affect its orbit or
orbital period
this would lead to dramatic climate
changes and even render the planets
completely incapable of sustaining life
however according to some estimates an
impact of even the biggest
asteroid in the solar system would not
be enough to do so
an object realistically able to
noticeably change the earth's orbit
should be as big as the moon or pluto at
the very least
be it as it may if it were to happen the
consequences of an impact of this scale
would be much graver than just a change
of orbit or orbital period
the potential impact risk of 1950 das
hitting our earth is just
0.012 there is no room for complacency
though as the impact probability may
rise
following a change of the asteroids
orbit as a result of collisions with
other celestial objects that may well
take place
for a long while it was believed that
the humanity hadn't advanced enough to
prevent any hazards of asteroid falls
all we could do was just observe
potentially hazardous objects
actually doing something about them like
destroying an asteroid or changing its
orbit was confined to science fiction
films and books
however science doesn't stand still even
in 2004 when a threat posed by apophis
was considered grave enough
it was proposed to cover its surface
with light reflecting film
this way sunlight pressure would change
the asteroid's orbit
other suggestions included nuclear
bombings as well as special power
thrusters powerful enough to shift
orbits of celestial bodies
[Music]
in 2018 nasa in collaboration with
spacex
approved the dart program whose aim is
to deflect the asteroid's trajectory by
making it collide with an artificial
spacecraft
the binary near-earth asteroid didymos
made up of two components with diameters
measuring 800 and 150 meters is the
target for the dart demonstration
the launch of the spacecraft is planned
for 2021
celestial bodies on the solar system may
be closely monitored but there is always
a risk of somebody previously unknown to
us
arriving from the galaxy's outskirts and
heading towards the earth
orbital periods of some comets and
asteroids around the earth may last
hundreds and even thousands of years and
their small sizes and dark surfaces
render these potentially dangerous
visitors barely detectable
still the odds of such a disaster as an
impact event are extremely small
and in fact there are many more dangers
that may before the human race
on our own planet
in this film we have talked about a few
phenomena mankind has come across
in our comparatively short history but
even with all the information
gathered by now it is impossible to say
with absolute certainty that science has
made any progress
in getting to the heart of the processes
taking place on our earth
the blue planet is an organism in its
own right
and it has its own unique features it's
going to take us
hundreds of years of meticulous research
to figure it out completely
and while the process of investigating
our planet is underway
i'll do my best updating you on the
details on the cosmo
channel let's keep in touch
you